so getting into the question does this
look
familiar wait for
it it's
coming one more
second there we go so as we just saw
slow plots lead to a boder experience
I'm shy I'm an N developer at abilon and
this is my worst nightmare so bottle Mi
can occur in different parts of the
process uh which are you first start
with data preparation so let's say you
fish data from your database you do some
aggregations before you start working on
your plot then you define your plot n r
using your favorite Library like I don't
know plotly or hrs4r
and later on all of the plot related
data and settings get sent to the
browser where your plots get rendered
and what I've discovered that there are
three main root causes of bottlenecks
happening in the blood rendering process
the first one being an inefficient data
preparation process so let's say you
want to visualize your home budget data
and you want to visualize it in form of
a box plot this is how you would go
about it in plotly and it makes it super
convenient to do INR so you plug in your
data set you pick your variable and you
pick your plot
type but let's focus on our first line
right here so how do we prepare the data
so that code here might work very well
for small data let's say you just have a
couple of rows but as your data gets
bigger you're essentially fetching all
of your data sets all of your data set
into the memory of your process just to
create a box plot so if you have million
of rows in the database that can be
pretty
inefficient but let's go back to our box
plot to plot a box plot you just need
five values the minimum value the lower
quartile the median the upper qual and
the maximum value so what if instead
fetching millions of rows you would just
calculate those five values on the
database site and plug in plug it into
your plotly function like
this sometimes we also try to show too
much and it can manifest itself in
different ways for example let's go back
to our millions of points and let's say
we're using a scatter plot to visualize
it rendering millions of points can take
a while perhaps you can convey the same
type of information using a different
plot again let's go back to the example
of the box plot where you can just
switch five values and show the perhaps
the similar information you want to
convey also when you're creating a
dashboard it might be very tempting to
put a lot of plots on your uh in your
dashboard but reality is users rarely
are able to focus on all of them at once
and rank explodes might take well so why
not instead just show one plot and
provide controls for your users to
switch between each type of plot to make
it
faster we sometimes also use our
plotting libraries inefficiently so a
lot of libraries provide convenience
functions like to webg on in plotly or
boost mode in High charter which
leverage a technology called webg which
makes use of your GPU to render your
plot in the browser faster and in some
cases there are some available options
like for example the highter rjon option
in the highter package and highter by
default uses a package called Json light
to prepare data and settings for the
browser and as your data gets larger it
can get a bit slow and R Json is a bit
more efficient and some users have
reported the 25x speed increase while
switching to our
Json all right thank you that will be it
for me and if you have any question you
can post them on the slide deck that's
been mentioned or if you want to talk to
me you can find me at the app on
[Applause]
[Music]
both